German company Siemens has announced it
will not be backing out of a deal to
provide infrastructure for a
controversial coal mine in Australia
that's despite growing pressure from
environmental groups who linked carbon
emissions to the bush fires devastating
large parts of the country there have
been protests at home and abroad since
it signed the deal in December but
Siemens as boss says there's no legally
and economically responsible way out of
the agreement to supply rail
infrastructure for the Adani mine well
for more on this let's speak to David
Ritter he's the CEO of Greenpeace sister
Australia Pacific and also the author of
a book about the Adani coal mine and he
joins us now on skype David let me start
with some promises from Siemens seaman
says it supports the Paris agreement and
it's also promised I see to be carbon
neutral by 2030 how does that square
with this decision
well Siemens has given itself an
enormous kick in the guts today it has
made a disastrous decision for its own
reputation and it's hollow commitment to
the Paris agreement goes to the heart of
that the development of the Adani coal
mine is completely inconsistent in
spirit with the Paris agreement so it
beggars belief that Siemens can actually
think it is committed to Paris while it
is supporting the construction of this
coal mine David I see I see that the CEO
of Siemens Joe Kaiser is saying that the
rail contract would be going ahead
regardless even if they pulled out so
are you pushing for more of a symbolic
gesture from Siemens then no absolutely
not I mean that is the drug dealers
defense
it's what anyone who is doing something
wrong for a profit always is in the
circumstances where they're caught out
the truth is that Siemens is providing
crucial services to the Adani company
and that it would be a body blow to the
project if Siemens pulled out now
Siemens should withdraw its contractual
commitment because of their own
commitment to the Paris agreement but
more so because the vast majority of
Australians are against the Adhan EEMA
I'm going ahead and particularly at the
moment in the context where as you say
Australia is being ravaged by terrible
unprecedented fires which are themselves
being made worse and generated by global
warming which the scientists are being
very very clear about and that is driven
in turn by coal above all else
so for Siemens to be supporting the
construction of this Adani mine at the
same time as Australia is literally on
fire is simply appalling corporate
practice
David you say Australians are an T the
Adani coal mine but I see the government
has quite a different a different stance
the Resources Minister wrote to Kaiser
last month pleading for him and I quote
not to be intimidated by the noisy
anti-coal minority targeting the mine
project and he wrote if the protestors
achieved their goals of ending coal
mining by bullying companies into
submission the result would be millions
more people without a home access to
electricity and without as much hope as
they otherwise could have what's your
response to that well that is an absurd
selective reading of things a majority
of the Australian people want climate
action that is very clear a majority of
the Australian people oppose the Adani
mine and it is not going to be old dirty
technologies like coal that provide
energy democracy and power to those who
need it it's going to be the new
decentralized technologies particularly
solar so I'm sorry but that is a very
self-serving line and it is a shame that
Siemens have bought it because the truth
is that Australia needs to move beyond
exporting and burning coal as fast as
possible to make good on our nation's
commitment to the Paris agreement and to
go will beyond that as a as a world we
have to turn away from coal as fast as
we possibly can so that we have a
livable climate in the future and I'm
afraid Siemens has really delivered a
body blow to it
reputation with this announcement today
and pressure will simply continue to
increase on the company from the tens of
thousands of people who are appalled in
Germany in Australia and around the
world as the lead up to the company's
AGM in February continues really this is
a sad day for Siemens David Ritter there
the CEO of Greenpeace Australia Pacific
thank you for joining us on al-jazeera
David